hey youtubers is charlie since comic-con
is this week and I'm gonna be doing a
bunch of Walking Dead stuff I wanted to
do a big preview video just like I did
for Game of Thrones so i'll be doing a
breakdown of the panels as well as the
trailer that are going to be airing and
all the other separate stuff that Robert
Kirkman's doing just for the comic book
I'll also be doing a walking dead
giveaway just like I'm doing for Game of
Thrones this week so I'll explain that
at the end hello any new people if
you're just finding me for the first
time I do weekly Walking Dead videos be
sure to subscribe to get everything I
know I just said I'm doing a Comic Con
giveaway but whenever episodes get here
I do a weekly giveaway for each of the
episodes big stuff first there are two
big panels one documentary screening and
to Robert Kirkman comic related panels
so they'll be walking dead stuff
happening each day of comic-con the big
hall h panel well they'll be screening
that season five trailer is friday july
25th at 12pm pacific time right now Game
of Thrones is beating walking dead in my
straw poll for which panels to upload
first but i'll still be uploading the
hall h panel that night i have links to
my Twitter and Facebook down in the
description so i will be tweeting during
the panel we're not allowed to post the
trailer online before AMC does but as
soon as they do i'll do a separate
breakdown video for that and don't worry
AMC will make that trailer available to
everyone so even if you're not a comic
con you'll still be able to see it
hopefully by Saturday they haven't
really announced which day they're going
to upload it but usually it's after the
panel I'm sure it'll make everyone
really happy and really sick to their
stomach at the same time just like last
year they're bringing most of the main
cast pretty much everyone that was
stuffed in train car a including Andrew
Lincoln Norman Reedus who's actually
doing a separate panel with Robert
Kirkman I'll explain in a sec Steven
Yeun lauren cohan Melissa McBride Chad
Coleman Michael Cudlitz Scott Gimple
Gale Anne Hurd Kirkman himself of course
Greg Nicotero and Dave Alpert Chris
Hardwick is moderating just like he did
last year and yes even though I'm a
partner at Nerdist that doesn't entitle
me to any special treatment they
actually don't produce talking dead
there's like a whole separate companies
so I totally have to stuff myself in
there like a sardine just like everyone
else it gets really smelly they're still
in the middle of filming season 5 but
they have been going full steam since
May so they should be almost done
filming about the first half of the
season if not a few more episodes after
that I say that just based on last
year's productions
well they didn't finish filming the
season 4 finale until November they will
announce the premiere date even though i
think we all expect it to be that second
week in october just like last year that
would put at october 12 but they could
always bump it by a week they also just
released the full comic-con banner it's
basically all the people inside that
train car chained up wouldn't it suck if
they daisy chained all those handcuffs
together they'd have to shuffle around
terminus like one giant glob of people
so the next big panel is norman reedus
in robert kirkman that's on saturday at
3pm that's for a movie that they did
together called air they made it through
kirkman's skybound label it's not a
walking dead movie it doesn't involve
those characters it stars reedus and
Djimon Honsou has two workers in an
underground bunker it's basically like a
post-apocalyptic world where everyone
has to hibernate underground because the
above world air is toxic so it does have
the DNA of walking dead in there in that
it's post-apocalyptic the movie won't be
out till spring 2015 but they will be
showing the trailer and for those that
don't know skybound is the label that
Robert Kirkman created the company
whenever he became a partner Image
Comics he used it to publish the walking
dead comic but now he's also using it to
make movies as well as video games while
they're doing that movie panel they're
also going to be talking about what's
coming next with the telltale Walking
Dead game and the other games are
developing the separate ones now rewind
to Thursday Robert Kirkman's going to be
doing his just walking dead comic book
panel at four o'clock p.m. it'll just be
for the comic book so he'll be answering
questions about all-out war new
beginning in the next story line after
that I'm not current with the comics
right now but I know a lot of you read
along with the show even though a lot of
times the show changes a bunch of stuff
vol 23 is going to be the next story
line after new beginning that's going to
start in October so they'll pry be
teasing that the last issue of the
current storyline new beginning is issue
132 that's going to be released october
eight that kind of supports the theory
that the season 5 premiere is going to
be the sunday right after that the 12 so
the next thing that's happening is a
Walking Dead documentary they're going
to be screening it's only 20 minutes
long but it's going to be friday at
five-thirty p.m. it's called a decade of
dead it's just about the evolution of
the comic and how it turned into a TV
show they'll probably end up adding it
to one of the dvds hopefully or maybe
even aired on TV so hopefully everyone
will get a chance to see it then on
Sunday Robert Kirkman is doing another
comic book panel for his other Skybound
comics that's the non walking dead ones
like
ghosted tech jacket and manifest destiny
so you should definitely check those out
if you're already reading walking dead
as usual AMC is bringing their walking
dead escape event to the petco park
outside the comic-con convention center
because it's outside you don't need a
badge to go see it it's only going to be
open on Friday and Saturday but it is
one of the coolest things to do if you
don't have a comic-con badge you do have
to buy separate tickets for it there's
different levels you can buy ranging
from like twenty dollars to seventy
dollars but it is really cool the
website for those tickets is the walking
dead escape calm if you buy the
expensive tickets the seventy dollar
ones they basically turn you into a
walker and train you like they train the
walkers on the show you also get full
makeup done that's why it costs so much
so for all the martyrs who just want to
know what new things they can buy this
is the stuff they're going to be selling
at the convention center the coolest
thing you can buy is negan's Lucille bat
they're going to be selling that along
with an Ezekiel figure I won't say where
he comes from because spoilers and then
there's a bunch of new minis including
hay-soos abraham and andrea those will
be sold inside the convention center at
the sky bound booth so you better get
there fast if you want to get them
because they're usually sold out by
sunday but they'll eventually start
selling them online okay so really big
reminders the most important stuff that
Hall H panel is gonna be on Friday I
should be able to upload the panel
footage by Friday night like midnight
it'll take a little while internets
pretty crappy but whenever they post
that season five trailer hopefully by
saturday i'll have another video
separate video just for that be sure to
subscribe to get everything it's gonna
be a lot of fun i will be tweeting
during the panel so if you do want to
follow me on social all the links for
that at the bottom of the description
and here's the details i might give away
i'm going to be picking one random
subscriber from the comments on this
video to get a Funko pop figure of your
choice of you can totally pick poncho
Daryl or the governor or whoever else is
available the giveaway is going to be
open all this week so I won't pick
someone to the week after comic-con and
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comments on the
video so right now click here to learn
about the new characters coming in
season 5 and click here to get a
breakdown of that special that they just
aired the season 5 special thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives
you